this week convict zone is in Brussels
and my guest is the Russian ambassador
to the EU Vladimir Churov not the
easiest job at the best of times and
these are hardly the best of times his
sole function seems to be to deny NATO's
accusations of aggression and throw them
back at the West so how believable is he
ladira cheese's
welcome to comfort zone thank you you
don't need me to tell you that it's a
bad time for east-west diplomacy that
neither side believes a word of what the
other is say so what are your
instructions from Moscow keep denying
and wait till better times I wouldn't
say it's a bad time for diplomacy I
would rather put it as a challenging
time for diplomacy because that's very
diplomatic of you well it's all right
time I mean relations are very fraught
it's a bad period a difficult period in
the relationship but it's a challenging
time for diplomacy because diplomacy is
a tool to straighten things out given
that it is this difficult time you gave
an interview last month to Western
interviewer and yes you did you're a bit
of denial you said there's no evidence
that Russia has made any aggressive
moves in Ukraine or against Ukraine
there was no invasion of Crimea indeed
who want us do you expect to believe
that
well if you look objectively at the
figures and at the legal basis for what
Russia did and what Russia did not do
regarding Crimea well the Russians seem
to have forgotten this avalanche of
condemnation that you got at the United
Nations two years ago basically when the
world turned down your idea I wouldn't
say Crimea inside Russia didn't they
Canada condemned the Russian
Federation's
unilateral and unjustified assault on
Ukraine well the country to country
European a country that has such a
sizable Ukrainian community as Canada
well perhaps that explains it
yeah but they didn't know there were
hundred countries who adopted a
resolution basically declaring illegal
the March 16th referendum
that changed the status of Crimea as far
as you were concerned a hundred
countries they didn't yet have sizable
Ukrainian population no indeed but the
hundred countries are a very small
majority of them UN member states to
begin with but you've got eleven voting
with you let's be honest a hundred
against eleven I know there were 58
abstentions
but you only managed to get eleven so
Moscow can't have been exactly thrilled
with your diplomacy at the United
Nations well I would say that in this
particular case it's not so much the
numbers at the UN that matter but the
numbers the percentage of people who
voted in the Crimean referendum and when
I say that allegations of Russian
invasion of Crimea are totally wrong I
can refer to the fact that there was a
Russian naval base in Crimea since the
18th century all along and how far do
you want to go back in history to say
that things were different I would say
that of course the population of Crimea
was more than 2/3 ethnically Russian and
if we refer to the language aspect of
the situation only 3% of the of the
Crimean population declared their
mother-tongue Ukrainian which was
actually less than those who declared
the crimean tatar language as their
mother tongue mr. Joffe this referendum
took place in a Crimea that was already
under armed Russian occupation foreign
guns were pointing at the people that's
a wonderful recipe for what your
president called an open honest and
dignified referendum is it I wonder how
dignified a referendum would be in
Moscow for instance if you had American
guns pointing at you while you voted
well actually the
again I referred to the legitimacy of
Russian military presence in Crimea in
those days according to the Russian
Ukrainian bilateral treaty of 1997
Russia had the right forum for military
presence both in Sevastopol which is the
major naval base but also across Crimea
at the level of 25,000 military
personnel the actual numbers when the
the crisis erupted over 16,000 much less
than the 25 the remaining gap of 9,000
was filled quickly yes by sending
additional reinforcements by plane
despite the people who took over the
buildings were in his words spontaneous
self-defense forces yes
yeah but the story changed a month later
on April the 17th 2014 when he said of
course the Russian servicemen did back
the Crimean self-defense forces
something he'd admitted to say earlier
they acted in a civil but a decisive and
professional manner this was your first
complete change of story without even a
blush I wouldn't say I wouldn't say it
was a change of story
actually this was confirmation of the
actual role the Russian military played
which was to provide safe and secure
environment for for the referendum and
the expression of political will by the
local population let's be honest here
your president was asked who these
people were these little green men who
were in uniforms where did they get
these uniforms and he said shops shops
that was his reply we know because
retired russian admiral igor kasatonov
spoke out in 2015 that the so-called
green men were Russian Spetsnaz Special
Forces there were six helicopter
landings from them and
three il-76 Russian transport planes
that brought in 500 of them so when your
president said March 4th that these
people were simply spontaneous
self-defense forces he was being
economical with the truth wasn't he
well I think he actually meant different
people those who were actively involved
in the changeover in Crimea semantics he
basically said that it's all locals and
then the story changed and you'd flown
in 500 Spetsnaz forces that's the
reality isn't it and then they code
coward crowed about having fooled NATO
kasatonov said well NATO didn't even
spot them coming in what a triumph it
was for us so you know he boasted about
it but you'd misled us by then so why
should we believe anything that you say
you misled us on this I think the
important part of this situation was
that the Russian troops who were there
actually didn't fire a shot there was no
actual finding in spite that the
Ukrainian military presence in scry in
Crimea in those days was at the level of
20,000 some of the best Ukrainian troops
so there was no military clash there was
no armed confrontation and very solemn
duty somtum of course that that's not a
military confrontation when you go in
and demand that they put down their arms
foreign force arrives helicopters and
il-76 plane demands that they drop their
arms that sort of military confrontation
I don't know what it is I think if the
Americans arrived in Moscow and did it
to your forces I think you'd call that a
more confrontational exactly that would
be a military comedy so so you're
arguing over semantics here the other
the other story that changed a lot was
the story about your troops being in
eastern Ukraine I mean for almost two
years we heard denials that Russian
servicemen were involved in eastern
Ukraine and then magically on December
the 17th last year
the poutine changes the story we never
said that there weren't people dealing
with certain tasks in the military
sphere but that doesn't mean there are
regular Russian forces there feel the
difference he said contrast that with
what he said eight months earlier I will
say this clearly there are no Russian
troops in Ukraine different story
different story again you mislead us
well you started by asking me about
diplomacy the role of diplomacy is
slightly different and how when you read
the other side how how can diplomacy
work to this extent
well diplomacy should taken into
consideration the objective situation
the realities on the ground and look for
ways to settle this crisis or any crisis
across the globe by diplomatic means
through political dialogue but when your
reality is so different from the reality
is seen by the hundred countries who
voted against your referendum at the
United Nations what what is that talk
about well that that I think the reality
as we all see today is some is an
objective picture we may disagree on the
explanations of the course of events be
two years ago be it
20 years ago be it a hundred years ago
but the reality on the ground that we're
facing should be the basis for - for
people including politicians and state
leaders to look forward that's very
difficult to do that when you continue
to deny an you have done over the last
two years that you've had troops in
eastern Ukraine even when some of them
have actually been caught by the other
side I'm in two examples
captain yevgeniy Arif EF and Sergeant
Alexander Alexandrov both identified
themselves as serving
members of your giu Special Forces taken
prisoner in eastern Ukraine in May 2015
in December 2015 mr. Putin was asked
about them he made no effort to discern
them instead he called for a calm
discussion about them and what he called
an equal prisoner exchange so he wanted
to exchange your proper Russian forces
in eastern Ukraine with some Ukrainians
that have been captured your forces were
there everybody knows your forces were
why for two years did we have this
deception that your forces weren't in
eastern Ukraine I mean we even had later
even put out satellite pictures look
there's a satellite picture 21st of
August commercial satellite picture
showing your forces within the sovereign
territory well that doesn't prove that
these self-propelled artillery pieces
belong to the Russian army no but they
were in a position where the Ukrainian
army wasn't so there is high probability
that they belong to your forces I mean
or they could be could belong to the
forces of the self-proclaimed Donetsk or
Luhansk Republic but we have so many
Russian sources now that have told us
over the last couple of years I mean
even the committee of soldiers mothers
valentina Magna cover who's a member of
your defense ministry's public council
she said that up to fifteen thousand
Russian troops have been sent to Ukraine
in August and September 2014 she's head
of she's a member of your Russian
Defense Ministry public council she's
not speaking nonsense well everybody has
the right to make him wrong judgment or
a mistake so what about Ilya Yashin who
co-authored with the murdered opposition
leader Boris Nemtsov the report booting
war he talked of how two hundred and
twenty Russians were lost in two major
battles in eastern Ukraine in August
2014 in February 2015 he said all the
key successes of the separatists were
secured by Russian army units plenty of
sources well that's his point of view
mine is different
so who's true I mean you have the weight
of evidence points and and the numbers
of Russian soldiers that have been
apprehended their son of course you
referred to but they were others who
said they lost their way they somehow
lost their way because maps maps are so
difficult to come by these days exactly
reliable maps it's so hard to get those
two that you referred to the at the time
when they were apprehended in eastern
Ukraine they were not an active duty
they weren't yes so that's not that's
another semantic issue isn't it well you
know it's difficult to prove things with
evidence that get lost and a lawyer for
one of those to get killed in Ukraine
but you know the OSCE Organization
Security and Cooperation in Europe I
mean they continue to condemn your
actions in Ukraine last summer the
Parliamentary Assembly talked of your
unilateral and unjustified assault on
Ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity my point mr. ambassador
people aren't buying your version are
they well simply not buying it that's 96
votes in favor of a resolution against
you seven against 96 volts that's
probably the result of an information
war launched against Russia and which is
continuing to this day you don't fight
in information wars either we have to
respond yes we do we are engaged in that
which is a new element of course in this
21st century of ours but your policy is
never admit a mistake never say sorry
Russia is always perfect well that's not
true nobody's perfect but it's all the
other side's fault not always there our
mistake
I think one of the if we look back to
the post-soviet period I think one of
the mistakes Russia did with the Russian
leadership of the time did was to to
press too much its Western partners yet
so ever mr. Gorbachev I oh and he's the
immediate successor you actually talked
about this didn't you in September 2014
you said in an interview that NATO had
promised it wouldn't expand eastwards
and that Mikhail Gorbachev had been
naive enough to believe those promises
yes but perhaps you should have checked
with mr. Gorbachev himself before you'd
said that because perhaps he knows a
little bit more about the situation
after he was there because a month after
you gave that interview he was asked by
Russia beyond the headlines whether the
West had lied about its plans for
Eastern Europe he said the topic of NATO
expansion was not discussed at all and
it wasn't brought up in those years I
say this with full responsibility not a
single Eastern European country raised
the issue not even after the Warsaw Pact
ceased to exist in 1991 Western leaders
didn't bring it up either so that's his
answer to your accusation of promise
well no it doesn't contradict all what I
said where are the promises because of
which I've added the agreement on a
final settlement with Germany said that
no new military structures would be
created in the eastern part of the
country no additional troops would be
deployed no weapons of mass destruction
will be placed there
Gorbachev said it has been observed all
these years Gorbachev said this was
observed but he didn't say that NATO
broken promises he said it's been
observed all these years this is this is
in your this is in your journal Russia
beyond the headlines
yes I can explain that with all due
respect to my former leader there were
certain promises made orally during his
and other discussions of those days in
the last you think he didn't know well
of course he knew but in the sense that
the is issue the issue of NATO expansion
main may not have been a formal subject
of of negotiations because I believe
that this issue was not perceived in
those days as realistic by the Soviet
side of the time but you you want to
discuss history well he brought it up I
mean you said you said this was a
mistake that Russia made in believing
the promises that I'm telling you that
the last leader of the Soviet Union said
there weren't any promises but I mean
let's say let's stay with now I can
assure you there were ok because you
continue to complain about efforts to to
humiliate Russia too politically and
militarily contain Russia but there's no
evidence of external humiliation of
Russia is there I mean after the USSR
collapsed what happened Russia was
welcome to the Council of Europe was
welcome to the World Trade Organization
closer relations with the EU
how humiliating was all that well first
of all I'm not complaining second you
referred to the WTO I wouldn't say that
Russia was particularly welcomed into
the WTO it took 18 years of tough
negotiations to get in and now we are
asking ourselves whether ourselves
whether it was worth the while I'd be
coming which may result in you know the
future of the WTO being put into
question you were welcome to the
nato-russia Council which was set up
specifically and you were promised that
as long as you respected borders in
Europe no substantial combat forces
would be moved east no nuclear
installations have been moved onto the
territory of new NATO members have they
and in response to Russian objections
Ukraine and Georgia were denied NATO
membership in 2008 I don't see much very
humiliating about that do you to Russia
well I wouldn't say they would denied
entry actually the Bucharest summit of
NATO produced a document document which
stipulates that those two countries will
be NATO members yeah but they weren't
they wanted it then and there
2008 and as you know george w bush said
no no it's not going to happen
president obama went even further he
changed the configuration of the
proposed missile defense installation in
poland suspended its phase 4 because
moscow didn't like it is that
humiliating to well these these issues
were were for many years the subject of
very heated I would say discussions were
very professional discussions with our
Western partner but recent developments
since you refer to missile defense I I
can say that the recent developments
which actually mean that phase 2 of the
global and the ABM system of the United
States is being completed with the
launch of a base in Romania that was
yesterday
you say the launch of a base this is a
missile defense installation indeed as
you know aimed at Iran what is the
purpose I would say Iran I don't speak
for the Americans but the American says
it's to deter an attack from Iran when
Iran doesn't have the means to reach
either Romania or any other European
country the Americans with disability
but its effect effect recognized by
everybody that the longest range of
Iranian missiles is below two thousand
kilometers on the other hand the the
international effort by my country other
Western countries and the European Union
has produced a comprehensive plan to
resolve the problem of the Iranian
nuclear program so right why would why
would NATO or the America the United
States see Iran as as a manager well you
have to ask them but you talk about your
contribution in the period let's talk
about the threat that NATO feels that
you pose between 2030 and 2050 in your
air activity close to NATO's European
airspace has increased by about 70
percent Allied aircraft scramble 400
times in that period to intercept you
they say you indulge in highly dangerous
behavior often you file no flight plan
you don't talk to air traffic
controllers and you switch off your
transponders and endangering civilian
aircraft why would you do something like
that why would you put civilian aircraft
in danger unnecessarily
well you refer to certain figures I
would say that a of military activity of
NATO in the same area during the same
period increased fourfold and NATO
military planes fly around with their
transponders shut off that's I'm asking
you why you fly with yours off a little
because there was an incident in January
last year where your ambassador in
London was summoned to the foreign
office to explain why civilian aircraft
had to be rerouted because your bombers
were flying up the channel and
disrupting air activity I will my answer
is quite simple its usual practice by
air forces of all countries including
Russia including NATO countries to fly
without transport with the transporters
shut off that's that's the usual
practice and - and in fly a hundred feet
above above an American warship in the
Baltic last month yes
warship Donald cook yes and worship
armed with cruise
and directed against the Russian naval
base in Kaliningrad well they didn't
fire and they didn't target it did they
but this was in direct violation of the
1972 agreement on the Prevention of
incidents on and over the high seas
where aircraft commanders are required
to use the greatest caution in
approaching aircraft and ships of the
other party which they did not which
they majored feet above them
that's great caution is it of course
it's it's the same of high
professionalism of Russian pilots
ambassadors teacher you get to have your
own conflicts oh thank you very much
you